PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
I'll admit gladly that I don't
like to drive, or cook, or get
groceries.
I'm lazy.
Sure, you can say that.
But I know there
are millions of you
out there like me, who would
rather Uber than drive.
Have you ever wondered how Uber
platform scales for millions
of concurrent users like us?
They must get billions of
database transactions a day.
I am absolutely fascinated by
how Uber designed its platform
to handle those insane
number of requests.
So I invited Ankit Srivastava,
senior staff engineer at Uber,
to learn all about it.
Stick around, because this
ride is going to be awesome.
Hi, Ankit.
Thanks for joining
us on the show today.
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA: Thank you
for having me, Priyanka.
Really glad to be here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So we
all know what Uber is,
but to kick-start
our conversation,
let's start with what powers
that simple experience
of clicking a button
to get a ride,
or get food at our doorsteps.
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA: You know,
Priyanka, the first time
I used Uber, I fell in love
with the simple experience
where I could get a car
at the tap of a button.
It seemed magical.
Being here at Uber for
the past six years,
and the pace at which
Uber is evolving
to become the essential for
day-to-day consumer needs,
I'm still learning all the
intricacies of various product
features that we have.
At a very high level,
when a consumer clicks
on the Get A Ride
or Get Food button,
we capture the user's
intent and fulfill it
by matching it with the right
set of providers nearby.
Fulfillment models the
user's intent as demand,
and any active
provider session that
can fulfill this demand
as supply in its systems.
We in the fulfillment
team at Uber
developed platforms to
orchestrate and manage
the lifecycle of ongoing
orders, jobs, and providers
across millions of active user
sessions around the world.
In essence, fulfillment
is a foundational platform
capability that powers
existing lines of businesses
and enables rapid scaling
of new verticals seamlessly.
The platform handles millions
of concurrent user sessions
and billions of trips per year,
across thousands of cities
globally.
We handle billions of database
transactions every day.
There are hundreds of
microservices at Uber
that rely on the platform
as a source of [INAUDIBLE]
for the accurate state of any
ongoing order, job, or a driver
and a delivery person session.
Now, the events that are
generated by this platform,
they're used by
hundreds of offline data
sets to make critical
business decisions.
500-plus developers extend the
platform using APIs, events,
and code, to build
120-plus unique fulfillment
flows across various
lines of businesses.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wow.
All right.
So this fulfillment
platform-- it
sounds like this is the
backbone of Uber's architecture.
Now, let's say I
ordered an Uber.
How does the request flow work
from the driver, to the rider,
to this fulfillment platform?
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA: When you
open the Uber rider app
and request a ride,
the request goes
through a series of
checks and validation,
and it eventually triggers
fulfillment to create
a new order for the consumer.
This order represents the
intent of the consumer,
and we translate the
intent to individual jobs
that need to be processed.
And we store all of this
information in Spanner.
Now, these jobs are periodically
read by our matching engine,
and offered to any open
provider or supplier nearby.
Now, we used to store
all of this data
in our on-prem database, and
we recently moved to Spanner.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK.
So what were the
challenges you were
facing with this
on-prem database
in this original architecture?
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA: We leveraged
a NoSQL storage engine,
Cassandra, to
maintain the real time
state of all fulfillment
entities on prem.
In order to maintain some
notion of serialized ability,
on top of Cassandra
we used Ringpop
to provide individual
entity-level serialization.
There were a few
major challenges,
but let me highlight
a couple of them.
Cassandra is built
on the paradigm
of eventual consistency.
In addition to that, in a
multi-data center setup,
it's really hard to guarantee
low-latency quorum writes
with Cassandra.
As Uber's products
and services evolved,
we started seeing complex
storage interactions
that required multi-row
and multi-table writes.
So we had to build an
application layer framework
to orchestrate this operation
by leveraging the saga pattern.
With the underlying storage
platform at Cassandra
being eventually
consistent, it often
led to inconsistencies that
had to be manually corrected.
What it translated in
the real world would be,
a rider seeing two different
drivers dispatched to them.
Imagine you being out
there near your office,
and there are two drivers
who arrive to pick you up.
It's a bit confusing
for anyone out there.
As we scale globally to
millions of active users,
even a notion of
consistency became harder
to achieve at our
application level.
In addition to all
of this, as we scale,
we started seeing horizontal
scaling bottlenecks, as well,
in the overall architecture,
and really, because of the way
we started with our
application layer with Ringpop.
This is when we started
tracing our steps back
to the properties of a
traditional SQL-based storage
engine that provides
asset guarantees.
We started defining a
transactional storage
engine that would
provide consistency
as the primary capability.
One of the things that has
been in mainstream technology
was New SQL storage
engines that combine
the scalability of
a NoSQL architecture
with strong ACID guarantees.
This is when we came across
Google Cloud Spanner.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Now, so that definitely
sounds like a lot
of trials, and then
figuring out what's working
and what's not working.
Definitely, the
eventual consistency
was not the aspect that could
be lived with-- especially
with this scale.
So what were the thought
processes and methodologies
that you were exploring when
transitioning from NoSQL to New
SQL?
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA:
When we were thinking
about the next chapter for
Uber's fulfillment platform,
the focus on consistency became
one of the primary evaluation
criteria, along with high
resiliency and availability.
Based on our requirements
and various benchmarks,
we evaluated various
New SQL storage
engines that were out there--
CockroachDB, FoundationDB,
and Cloud Spanner.
Cloud Spanner provided all
the functional requirements,
it scaled horizontally
with our benchmarks,
and provided us with a managed
solution for cluster management
and maintenance.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now, how
does the new fulfillment
architecture with Spanner work?
Can we dive into
the architecture?
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA: Yeah.
We leveraged Spanner's
North America multi-region
configuration as
the storage engine
for all fulfillment entities.
Our fulfillment
service transcends
Uber's own operational regions,
which are in North America
as well, and they make a
sequence of network cores
across to Spanner,
which is deployed
in Google Cloud for every
transaction that a user makes.
So for every user request,
or any system operation,
it results in a transaction
against one or more rows
and across one or more
tables in Cloud Spanner.
With Spanner we
are able to provide
a consistent view
of all our data
to internal as well
as external customers.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
it sounds like Uber
leverages this
hybrid of on-premise
and Cloud Infrastructure.
Now, knowing that keeping
latency to the minimum
is the biggest factor
for an app like Uber,
how do you set up the
networking architecture that
enabled that seamless and
lowest latency interaction
between this fulfillment
application layer on premise
and then the Cloud Spanner,
which is in Google Cloud?
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA: Thanks
to Uber's global networking
infrastructure team and Google
Cloud platform's networking
team, we have built an extremely
resilient and highly reliable
network infrastructure to
support Uber's workload.
In order to achieve this,
we separated the networking
infrastructure into
two major components--
the physical layer,
that consists
of the interconnections between
Uber and the Cloud vendors,
and a logical
layer, that consists
of virtual connections on
top of the physical layer
to achieve redundancy.
We built redundancy
across these layers
by having multiple
routers and local access
points at each
physical network route,
and an additional
layer of redundancy
with the logical
connections on top.
We even leverage Google's
private Google access
throughout all of Google's
traffic, the Google APIs
through the Cloud
interconnect VLAN attachments.
This reduces the need
of routing the traffic
through public
internet, and provided
additional reliability.
To validate our
architecture, the teams
came up with a
benchmarking suite that
validates all the physical
and logical network routes
extensively, and we
find any inefficiencies
in this test set
up very quickly.
This was extremely
critical for the success
of the overall project.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
I can only imagine
how connectivity
and those benchmarking
tests must have been so
critical to make this happen.
Now, you've been on Spanner
for quite some time.
How did the transition
to Spanner help?
What were the benefits?
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA:
You know Priyanka,
building a specialized
database is extremely complex,
and maintaining or
operating it is much harder.
With consistency as a primary
feature provided by Spanner,
and it being a managed
solution, they're
able to leverage a ton of
storage functionalities
out of the box.
This has given us
time back to focus
on building the
domain of fulfillment,
and provide our customers
with richer experiences.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
I cannot even imagine,
when you were migrating
to Cloud Spanner,
we were still ordering
food and rides.
How did the team make sure that
the migration and switchover
were seamless so that
the end users could
have the same experience?
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA: This
was extremely tricky.
One of the things that we
agreed upon from the beginning
was an internal
platform re-architecture
should not impact the
consumers in any way.
So we focused on building
the technology that
would seamlessly
migrate any ongoing user
session from our
old architecture
to the new Spanner-based
architecture.
Now, since the data
models and database
topology of our old platform
was significantly different
from the new architecture
that leveraged Spanner,
any kind of light migration
of data was ruled out.
Initially, given the fact that
most of this data is ephemeral
and continuously
changing every minute,
doing a light migration
through backups
will only result
in loss of data.
So we built a system
that intercepts
a request from a user
session and [INAUDIBLE] them
to the world where the
user session started.
If there are any ongoing
orders for the session,
we do not migrate
the user session
until the order is completed.
For an open user session
with no active orders,
we switch them to
the new architecture
which is backed by Spanner.
Now, the team automated all
of this through tooling,
and we tested the
tooling rigorously
in our testing, staging,
and shadow environments.
We even set up
test cities, where
we simulated hundreds
of riders and drivers,
and their behavior
in the real world,
to ensure we can observe the
impact of this migration.
And these migrations
were done by one city
at a time, in some
cases a batch of cities,
and it took more than
six months to complete.
Spreading this migration
over six months
also helped us to continuously
migrate business features
from the old stack
to the new stack.
There were 120-plus
business features
that were to be migrated from
the old stack to the new stack.
So the overall technical
and execution perspective,
it was a very difficult
and challenging project
that we undertook as a team.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
You're literally
changing, like, the tires of
the car while the car is going.
So [LAUGHS].
Yeah, I can totally imagine
how those benchmarking tests
and those tooling would
have been a critical part
of this entire migration.
When you run planet-scale
architecture like this--
and I don't use the word
"planet scale" a lot, but here,
it aptly fits, because this
platform handles millions
of concurrent users and billions
of trips per month across over
10,000 cities--
which translates to billions
of database transactions a day.
There is a lot happening.
Optimizing and operating
Spanner at that scale
must be crucial, because you
need to keep the costs low
and performance high.
So let's bring in Pritam
Shah, engineering director
for Cloud Spanner,
who helped Uber bring
this architecture to life.
Hi, Pritam.
So nice to have you.
Walk us through the
migration journey
and the challenges that come
with this scale of migration.
PRITAM SHAH: Thank
you for having me.
On the migration
planning front, there
are five things I can talk
about in terms of challenges.
First, how do we
test at Uber scale,
and how do we review
the experience
that a rider would have,
and the performance metrics,
so that we know we are ready?
So designing and executing
this test is a real challenge.
Second is agreeing
on migration first
with acceptable
performance, and then
fine tuning for better cost
and performance optimization
was another challenge.
The third one would
be capacity planning.
So how do we right size,
and have the right amount
of capacity in Spanner?
The fourth one, which is one
of the most critical ones,
is how do we do this
migration with zero downtime?
So doing a live migration
with no disruption
to Uber's business is
quite a bit of challenge,
and how do we do it in phases,
while keeping the lights on?
And the fifth one is
partnering with Uber
to ensure that everyone
is set up for success.
So, for example, after
the migration is done,
what kind of observability
and introspection
do we need in place?
What kind of alerting
The data protection
strategy, and the playbooks
for incident management.
The key was getting
aligned on a common goal,
and agreeing where we
want to be by what time,
and partnering closely
with Uber in this journey.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
You're really giving us
a truly behind-the-scenes look.
Even I was curious
to know what happens,
what needs to be done
to make this happen.
Any business with Uber scale--
obviously, no pun
intended-- will truly
benefit from just learning
what these steps were.
And it also
underscores that this
is possible to accomplish
a migration of such scale,
and how to actually
even get there.
So Ankit, I want
to ask you, what
are some of the
performance optimizations
that were done to deliver
this kind of user experience?
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA:
As Pritam mentioned,
I think the more important part
was during the migration phase,
figuring out what is the right
amount of observability we need
across the board
to ensure that we
can find these kind
of inefficiencies
quickly and iterate on them.
This operational rigor, giving
attention to various dashboards
metrics, and diligence in
evaluating every abnormality,
was extremely critical.
So some of the performance
optimizations that we worked on
in collaboration
across many teams
were primarily focused
on the networking stack.
The two primary issues that we
foresaw in the networking stack
was around the TCP resets
and intermittent packet loss.
By optimizing the
gRPC channel pool,
whenever a channel is
affected by the TCP resets,
the requests are automatically
forwarded temporarily
to a backup empty gRPC channel.
This allows for the request
to be forward instantly,
without having to wait
for a new Spanner session.
In a contained environment,
we saw improvements
of 1.7 times to 7 times the
average 2.5 time reduction
of errors.
Similarly, another common cause
of suboptimal availability
guarantee is
intermittent packet loss.
Recovering from these
conditions can sometimes
be in order of minutes,
further degrading
the overall application
performance.
With frequent
health checks we can
detect broken TCP connections
within five seconds,
and initiate a
graceful reconnect
on broken gRPC channels.
With these improvements, we were
able to reduce the total number
of errors by almost four times.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wow, those
networking improvements--
it sounds like they were so
critical to this whole setup.
Now, Pritam, how do you
optimize for cost when
using Spanner at that scale?
PRITAM SHAH: Yeah,
we did a few things
to optimize for cost for Uber.
So for example, we
optimized node utilization.
So in case of a
multi-region configuration,
a read can be issued to the
leader or to the replica.
If a strong read is
issued to the replica,
it incurs the extra
cost of latency
until the replica has
the latest snapshot
to serve the strong read.
To reduce the impact on latency,
we leveraged Google's Private
Service Connect and rerouted
the strong reads to the leader
region, and all the
stale reads were routed
to the replica-only region.
This helped us in maximizing
the utilization of the nodes
across the leader and
the replica region.
There are other cool
things that Ankit and team
have done on the latency
and cost optimization.
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA: Yeah.
In addition to the Private
Service Connect, which
optimizes how the traffic
routing works across the leader
and replica region, we also did
an autoscaler and on-prem cache
to improve the overall
latency and cost.
As you're aware that Uber's
traffic pattern is variable
by the time of day and week, we
provision for maximum capacity
at all time based resources.
To take advantage of Cloud
Spanner's elasticity,
we built an autoscaler
that constantly [INAUDIBLE]
the number of nodes based
on CPU utilization target.
So as the traffic is variable
based on a constant CPU
utilization target, we're able
to achieve maximum elasticity
out of the Cloud
Spanner cluster.
Similarly, most of our
workload is very read-heavy.
So we built an on-prem cache to
improve the latency and cost.
To maintain the same
consistency as Spanner,
we only route the
stale reads to Spanner,
and we allow our cache to
serve snapshot isolation based
on Spanner's [INAUDIBLE] time.
We built a query
caching functionality
to serve just the stale reads
from cache that is hydrated
by strong reads and writes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wow.
Awesome.
OK, so what I heard is
networking optimizations,
caching, and also autoscaling.
Well, awesome.
Ankit, Pritam, thank
you so much for sharing
such a complex system design,
architecture, and migration
story with Cloud
Spanner as a star.
I am absolutely
blown away seeing
what it takes for my Uber
ride to show up reliably.
PRITAM SHAH: It was absolutely
a pleasure partnering with Uber
on building the
fulfillment platform, which
is the backbone of
Uber's architecture.
And every time I
take an Uber, I will
get to tell my kids that the
ride was powered by Spanner.
ANKIT SRIVASTAVA:
Thank you, Pritam.
Thank you, Priyanka.
It was awesome to be here
and share our journey.
With Spanner as
a building block,
and a redesign of our
application data models,
we have truly laid
the foundation
for our next chapter, where
we are working on scaling up
platform infrastructure
by almost 10 times,
and building and modeling
many complex business features
and verticals on top.
We are truly on day
one of this journey,
and there's lot
to do and explore.
We're hiring.
Come join us and
be a part of it.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, now you know
what it will take
to scale and handle
an application with millions
of concurrent requests.
It's not magic--
it's Google Cloud
Spanner, and some planning.
Did this help you?
Let me know in the
comments below.
If you're curious about any
other use cases, drop a note,
and I will do my best
to bring that to you.